at this point like when you see these
types of things posted do you think is
is real like i mean is there how do we
fact check this you don't i don't think
it's real did you hear recently there
was uh
you i think i was with you yeah there's
a conspiracy theory that people believed
about birds not being real do you know
that
it was on 60 minutes
this guy started a conspiracy saying
that there's no such thing as birds
there he is birds aren't real and they
had a million people show up who is this
guy but he knows that birds are real
okay great so he started this conspiracy
to kind of study how conspiracies like
all these other conspiracies you
couldn't get people to glom on no didn't
he start it because he wanted to sell
t-shirts yeah
yes yeah as a joke and he sold
millions millions of t-shirts birds
aren't real dot com look at all the
t-shirts and people believe that people
believe that these are these uh uh get
out of here yeah they're uh put in the
sky by government for surveillance and
to attack us surveillance yeah that
these birds are spying on us well they
just can't do it in the phones enough so
they're like we need some backup but why
is that any crazier than believing that
the government that the vaccine
is there to put a chip in us
or do you believe that no the chip's
already in us man okay
yeah i think once you had your first can
of pringles you were [ __ ] you know
you were dialed in had a great
conversation with 60 minutes tonight
look how much he did
earlier this month biden was pooped on
by a bird
[Laughter]
yeah did you look that up birds don't
exist it's a real conspiracy a real fake
conspiracy theory that really took off
it's huge this is amazing
when this okay a couple days ago wow
oh no that's huge do these people that
also are they also like non-holocaust
believers is it the same group but the
truth is there it takes as much to
believe
that birds aren't real as it does to
believe that the holocaust didn't exist
as to believe that the um vaccine is a
conspiracy
to believe whatever you want to believe
it's the same
mindset yeah you know and it just shows
us how
based on timing and placement wait and
does anyone back there believe that
birds aren't real great question jeremy
jeremy step forward man no he believes
birds are real he's sitting beside a
bird that's being nursed back to health
right now alex is the leader of the
drone bird that bird is a drone yeah
you know amber heard actually said that
it was the bird that uh pooped in johnny
depp's bed yeah
the shit's not right johnny was like the
birds aren't real
that's a good johnny depp oh is it
do you do impressions a few yeah what do
you do that was a good job
um so basically during the trial amber
heard said that she didn't poop in my
bed and i said well i tasted it it's
real human [ __ ] so it must be
but also birds aren't real so
that's what happens but my friend alex
who nursed a bird back to life um we
called the bird um
uh well there's no name right now alex
didn't name the bird because he doesn't
want to get close to it but he did put
its mouth
on its mouth and so
um anyway when i was filming pirates of
the caribbean too
we had this scene and it gave me the
idea for chocolate which is a great name
for alex's bird if you would return my
texts
[Music]